around 4 million people live in
Waterboro on the north coast of jakarta
many stay in unsafe buildings and
partially submerged streets like this
isa Watty has had to raise the
foundation of her home because of high
tides and rain that have caused flooding
in the area and that's because parts of
Indonesia's capital are sinking London
sea used to be the same level unlike now
then they started building hotels and
roads that's led to flooding we keep
trying to raise our land higher but
water keeps coming in under water
digging and growing development is
causing the land to sink into Carter Bay
as water is pumped out the ground
gradually subsides only 60% of jakarta's
population has access to a piped water
service which means many have to use
wells flooding is also common especially
during the rainy season some of the
rivers that run through the city are
unable to drain water in 2017 a powerful
deluge hit more about destroying
hundreds of homes when the wall broke I
heard a noise like an explosion Walter
came in like a little tsunami my husband
was pushed by the washing and broke his
collarbone we had to rebuild everything
parts of North Jakarta have sunk by up
to 20 centimeters a year in several
areas along the coast are below sea
level this mosque couldn't be salvaged
now left lying half submerged the
government has since built defenses to
protect the city's coastline but they're
also sinking into the mud this giant sea
wall was built by the government to
prevent the sinking but sea water is
still seeping through the cracks and
many here say that without a long-term
plan Jakarta could be lost in the coming
years and part of a sea wall collapsed
last month adding further pressure
authorities have also tried to enforce
restrictions on extracting water and new
pumping systems experts say it's not
enough to save part of Jakarta from
going underwater it's a fast respond
against the sinking and the flooding
yeah and then but it is like a
painkiller only so we need to find a
cure for a real decision which is
substitute the groundwater exploitation
so we ask for water better water
management to the government all the
while sea levels are still rising
because of climate change and many here
in Jakarta say they have nowhere else to
go
Rahila mohammad al jazeera
jakarta